for
[Music]
okay so I go here and what do you you
want to get what do you want to do okay
cut it we P you we pass open and
grab here this ring tie right here you
have the wrist and you have the elbow
and of course you
have and we start
one I'm going to just follow the what
he's doing step out of the way kit 10
back
in okay let's
try uh you can fine so you know this
this thing here on nag a lot of people
are on on the inside and they like cut
down like
that and you don't you take away your
Zona Sanctuary because once you're on
the inside then you can come around and
do things okay so just more
important on the KN that you stay on the
outside and this is where the adhesion
skills come in is I as he goes to pass I
don't need to move him by going to the
inside I have to stay on the outside so
he goes and I'm on the outside always
protecting my area I'm on the
outside and I'm adhering there there's
the opening I want I come in boom hug
this thing okay you can of course take
the leg out any number of ways but you
have so much leverage
here well keep this tight this part
Tight cuz there's a elbow right okay if
he keeps falling fall slowly till you
down
okay so I do my move I come around he's
doing his move you see and here's your
y right there so he he's coming this way
you round it and then you have
the tensi Nugget
varation slow
[Music]
you know what I mean by
it here you're
yield right H 10
so just like every yield you're not just
getting out of the
way okay he's got it
still you have to
get get Center
[Music]
okay did you get it no sense all right
go over
here
do okay try why I think this is
important is that you do in Kon Wasa
it's so controlled and become so
familiar over
time and then the instructor has to go
you're never going to get that today so
we'll push that back till another year
etc etc and so you start to do K and
waza in a totally um unnatural way like
you're a robot or something and it'll
never translate into a conceptual
understanding let alone an application
uh ability okay so we know for example
just on tyo henko you see we go back he
has spinal displacement right oh when do
I enter into a iy communion with
him already already you see and then we
know so that as as he starts to move
you'll see that I'm already
moving and as he starts to touch slow
slower so we can see as he starts to
touch just focus right here there's the
touch I'm already working that
okay so likewise when I we go here and
we come around there's the pressure on
the other hand go back one step okay
we're here he's going out there's the
grip there's already pressure there do
you see great wa so don't keep it keep
it so this is where do do you feel that
okay so you're already in the center
then he does the other hand and now you
you're really Hy okay now as he's
holding hold this arm Tight cuz that's
what he's trying to do right rabbit like
you mean it I cannot
camera I cannot manipulate you better
grab it I'm going cut the out of
you okay I cannot do anything with this
arm so don't the arm is relaxed the body
throws but in Keyhole you're not
supposed to use your arms but you keep
getting away with it okay we use the
body so in
boom then your arms free now you go now
you use your arm do it again you come on
this
side oh I'm sorry you're going to be on
the other side
go Bo there's it already moving watch go
back one step he's he's moving I'm
already moving you see not
here then I move too freaking late
you're gone
right when he
touches you're in his Center you're
already in his Center okay so push my
arm he's not going to push my arm you
see that you get it I'm not here like
that there's a connection already and
I'm guiding this thing he's moving you
take him into the Tilt
enter arm body moves arm stays with him
home okay same principles in Kon but
we're missing it in Kon hence this kind
of training let's
try for
same beginning boom he goes I'm on the
outside right I'm trying for this you
feel the pressure I'm on the outside
again you see
W pop on the elbow there's pressure on
the
elbow same
beginning adhesion on the outside I'm
going for it but he's going ahead of me
it's coming back
in pressure on the elbow okay don't and
for for real what he has a knife don't
go like that keep the pressure okay keep
keep the grip don't let go over a
rattlesnake's head don't change that
one two I'm going here it comes
boom in stay over
here one see how there's Constant
Contact Boom come on dude it's your
life so don't let that I go behind you
then your counters
there okay
try Okay so as you're training this
don't push this out here you just enter
it okay also you're going into the
Russian tie even
more your counter is very short boom
right there
boom catch it you see that's what he's
doing here he comes camera see he's got
the Trap and there's the elbow he's
getting
boom okay let okay so we know the first
move and he's trying for this cut right
there so I'm on the
outside okay and I'm going for the
Russian tie there's the counter you see
how I stick with it okay and I
yield can can he come in to me no no if
I stay here there's a Yong Yong moment
there and he can go around
it so I'm yielding and watch where does
this where can this hand pick it up l in
the center line do you see that so you
don't go over here you're doing
everything just fine can it be in place
yes you see and now I'm here got it if I
move here that's not the Russian tie do
you get it cuz I that was your planted
foot you were going here that foot's not
available so stop dreaming you know
tissier does this stuff all the time he
goes and they go like this you see that
no your yield is on your feet so I take
weight off you see my weight shift
you see that it picks up push elbow into
a more secure control
Point keep your hands in front of you
keep contact with him boom
boom
small elbows always inside
[Music]
never coming on or off okay try it
again push into me so you can see you
see he's trying to push into me there
he's cutting push into me same thing
he's trying to push into me see I take
it on the curve he's coming in he's
cutting back on back at me right push
into me that's what he's doing I yield
here I am in front you see and I'm going
to expose the elbow is what I want so
this hand is going to curve around right
there from this contact Point curves
around right there's the
elbow right here curves around there it
is right there okay where you have that
braak you take his
balance then you
secure okay this is where you are in
this drill
no control control just like we're doing
our any of our sticky hand drills right
you feel the control you presses I yield
he's pressing boom he's pressing I keep
contact okay go
coming
in I feel the pressure change there's
there it is
again there's a pressure
chain right there is where he starts to
go y
right he goes y
okay get there so what I've done in that
flow is just like if we're doing the C
game right he's trying to hit my chest
right and he will feel that adhesion do
you see and he's going to try to get off
of it you see I followed it to the next
Y part that's what we're doing
here so I go
one two I fall I am attacking but now
I'm transition there it is again and I
want that okay as I'm not going to do
this though in combat because I'm
standing in the middle of him you see
that so again
one boom I feel it
he starts to go and this is right entry
right
there don't just swing your arm is what
I don't
want have to have his body into the
technique P there is
got hey try it
all right uh two Corrections
I'll repeat the first one okay so the
first one is when you're coming around
here you should feel that you're that's
what you are cuz he's doing Yang so you
have to match the Yang if you go if
you're under yangong he's going to get
you okay this isn't a yield this is an
iy adhesion I have to match the Yang the
Yang is very strong okay and as he goes
you can see that hand right there and
the elbow is my throwing mechanism you
see that okay so as he's here I'm inside
the grip move that just like we did stay
where you
are you see I on me and your throw
here again he has his elbow only I take
advantage of the elbow so I use the
elbow too you're he it on the
elbow and together don't pull this don't
pull this you're going to feed the fulc
you use the two very much like you were
using the body here he's on the two1 one
and I'm using the body I'm not trying to
strengthen his grip on that elbow tricep
you do that you're going to make it all
stronger I leave it where it is and I
use all of that Tre here and we go back
I use all that Tre here you see don't
pull use the two and then the next next
thing is we always attack the leg I
don't know which one you're going to get
if it's this one or if it's
both but don't throw like
this you kind do it slow if your partner
can't do it or you need to H that X po
this way
okay try it